so
in our art
a modern is going to struggle with
the techniques are just material
they're just skeletal alignment
musculature biomechanics
and
leverage
okay
of course you have that that
large and ever growing group of
aikido people
who
[Music]
are doing some sort of choreographic
dance
we have to not talk about them they
don't have these issues so they don't
make those misunderstandings that i just
described okay
anatomical alignment
muscular biomechanics
leverage these things are part of the
arts
but they are not the whole of the art
there is an energetic or an internal
aspect to the art all of those things
are material
they're external because they're
material i can see them i can feel them
i can touch them
okay
i can see them
it's a material
why is it so dominating our art because
we live in the age of material
and that's we're just
seeing ourselves
everywhere it's just egocentrism okay
the internal aspects of the art are
called kokyu
[Music]
they follow the same yin yang theory
because the art is based in yin yang
so they are interrelated
they are from the same source
they are co-dependent
but they are not exactly the same thing
and they are not any of the
aforementioned
okay
just like every form
your end goal is to transcend form your
end goal is to free yourself
from the mechanism or the vessel of
introduction
so i'm going to use a drill
to introduce
kokyu and aiki
but
kokyu and ikey are not restricted to the
drill
if your cloquia and ikey can only
manifest in the drill
i would tell you you're not
understanding koku and nike okay just
like if your
techniques if your self-defense
applications or your professional
utilization of the art is restricted to
a keyhole maza i'm going to tell you you
don't understand the key one was
okay that's just the vessel of
introduction
the most efficient way of learning kokyu
and aiki is to start with koku
from kokyu iki comes because of their
interrelatedness okay
you don't get ik first i haven't seen it
i myself didn't work it that way
and uh even though the art is called
aikido you're not doing aikido for a
very long time because you're not doing
ikea okay
first you have to develop poke
the vessel of introduction here is going
to be
i'm going to establish a ground vector
i'm going to align
my weight
as a resistance
you see as force is energy
on my midfoot
vector
your midfoot
is in the middle of your foot so
it's in
not on this side towards the big toe not
towards the little toe it is in the
middle of my foot
and it is slightly behind
where the ball of the foot is so you're
not on the ball of your foot
it's right here
okay
if you want you can think of it where
jesus got nailed
that's where it goes okay
i'm going to put my mass
my weight
because it's energy
i'm going to put it on that
alignment you're going to have to bend
your knees fix your head fix your arms
so that it stays
on there
okay
this is gonna be drill one
you can move your arms and you're going
to see like if i don't adjust knees and
hips then it's coming off of that you
see that
so once you get it static
okay
there
i want you to slowly move and you're
going to have to move different parts of
your body to keep your weight
on that nail
do you understand you could you can go
really slow
you can move your head
but you want to keep the weight
always on that part
okay all right drill one
so right now
your material mind is thinking oh yeah i
can stand straight over that
and it makes sense that the weight is
dropping down onto my mid foot but if
you pay attention this weight is not
over your midfoot which is why it's
starting to pull me over so i can take
this energy the resistance the weight
the gravitational pull on my hand
and i can
shift it onto my midfoot do you see such
that it's just pressing down my midfoot
now
you want to free your mind that you can
only align energy and straight lines
okay so that okay weight over mid foot
yeah okay no you were doing it just fine
the actual weight line is over here but
you move different parts of your body to
get back to mid-foot vector
in the same way
if i'm doing the shoulder press
and the bar is starting here
let's just get to the top
you're like oh yeah i understand
midfield
but you can take the bar
and move and you're going to see if i
don't adjust what's going to happen
it's going to take me forward
so i can take again
and not
directly align force
and make it go
on my mid foot
i can put it down the same way mid foot
mid foot mid foot i'll go off foot
calibration and watch what's gonna
happen you see
i calibrated still mid foot mid foot mid
foot mid foot mid flip mid foot mid foot
and just hanging out here
same thing goes on something a little
bit more dynamic it's now not linear
i do the same thing
pick it up
right now my weight is on my midfoot
if i stop calibrating it's going to make
me go forward mid foot
mid foot mid foot mid foot
up mid foot mid foot mid foot one foot
home mid foot
up boom hop mid foot
okay
so force does not have to be
or energy does not have to be in a
direct alignment to midfoot okay
here is energy his push
i can align this energy
to go on the midfoot of the back leg
okay
so he's pushing
and i feel the back leg rounding
he's just pushing the back leg down
contrast
with that would be what i call a bracing
angle
here's where you have an exact opposite
energy
pushing into him
you see that
that already you have left the arc
because this is a competing angle
that means i'm contesting him
when i have the internal aspect and he's
pushing
do you see i'm not competing with him
his energy is passing through me and you
don't even need both legs down he's just
pushing me down
okay
do you see that
we'll go on the other side
to get it on both sides of our body so i
take this energy
just like the non-aligned vertical
energy i'm now taking a non-aligned
lateral energy
and putting it on the back foot the mid
foot align that and you'll feel it press
down he's pushing me down
if i stop calibrating what's going to
happen
and
once you get yourself there you can test
for it
are you just pushing me down i can feel
oh wow it's getting heavier and then you
can see that you don't need
the front leg
okay
again as i said the vessel of
introduction
is not
what
you ultimately want to end up with
if you look at this conceptually i can
take any
energy
even the one any not aligned directly
with my midfoot
and transfer that weight
to my midfoot
does that make sense
well
in the same way
this energy of my mass
is not at all involved with the process
you can do
the same thing you could change it
okay
do you see it if if i'm taking his
energy and grounding it it doesn't this
energy too of my posture
is not
what i'm dependent upon
okay but we're going to start with the
vessel
the introductory vessel keep your mass
pressed
onto the midfoot
then take his energy
and press it onto the midfoot of the
backflow okay
let's try it so there is another skill
that you need
prior to this but we're we're moving
into this part okay and one of them is
that you can actually hold your four
corners in relationship so i have my
hips and my shoulders are in
relationship and that you can extend
that down to your knee and your foot
okay so if i don't have that skill when
he goes to push he's turning me and the
energy's going around me it's a little
harder for us
that can't keep our four corners in
alignment or
in relationship to ground the energy
here because it's spilling out through
my right shoulder you see that spill
that energy is supposed to go here
okay
um
his energy is going down his energy is
coming in and going down just like the
energy of my
mass is going down his energy's doing
the same thing
it is hitting a superior body
the planet
okay
it is going to be the energy that is
displaced
not the planet i'm not gonna move the
planet okay so it's very much similar to
a ball that hits a superior mass
it'll change directions
okay
in the same way
that i can take any energy not just one
in direct alignment but oriented back on
the midfoot i can take that rebounding
energy and rebound it at any angle that
i need okay
but we're going to start with the easy
one
just straight back out just like this
ball is doing it
unlike the ball i have lots of joints
and fluids and things like that and
that's why i could do something
different than the ball could do
if you change this ball so it's not like
this shape and it has many different
angles you're going to see that it too
can change the angle different from how
it hit the ground okay
so
i'm going to aim the energy that he's
given me
it's going down down and i'm holding it
down because i'm the one that's putting
it on the midfoot
i'm going to aim it back through his
center
i'm just going to shift my weight
so again
if he's coming at me and i shove him
back that would be contestation because
that's my energy against his energy
but in pre-modern understanding
that was when i projected him that was
his energy not my energy so technically
i'm not contesting him
okay
so it's his energy
let it go down
and then as you go to move forward
that's more energy make that energy go
down and conjoin with his energy and now
you can
project out
if you go like this
that's going to be contestation that's
material okay not energetic i want like
the ball the ball did not compress and
get ready to bounce you see the ball
just stayed the ball and let the earth
displace it same thing here he pushes
he's pushing down and boom
boom
keep it at at this uh
visible a level for now okay
you're he's pushing down take your
movement down two and then
push on to that
ground pattern
uh and you're gonna get him to displace
okay all right let's try that
um again this is a vessel of
introduction right it's not self-defense
so you don't have to go through a group
you liked
okay you stand there like that
that is just idiotic
okay
what i'm doing is simplifying
and idealizing
the environment for skill development
okay that's what you're doing
so he's not an opponent
he's not someone that's trying to grab
me to punch me
he's not even someone who likes and
wants to hold my hand he's not he is no
different
than the ball
or the barbell
do you see i didn't the barbell at the
ball had no emotional investment
in me
it's just a tool
okay
if you when you go let's say here oh
this looks like what i know this looks
like what i know right it's the same
thing i i have my energy
i would have his energy you see that's
his mass
i'm going to send that energy down into
the ground and i i would use that boo
to do the same exact projection
do you see and now now the idiot can go
i recognize that
okay
but you can't do it
because all you would do is hit the
surface of the guy with shoulder muscle
strength hip rotation okay
this is how you learn it
so he is more like a very sophisticated
slam ball or barbell
okay
so he's giving me energy
he's pushing down
he's very alive
and i have to there's all this micro
shifting that's happening in him and all
that has to go down i don't have to do
that with the ball or barbell you see
this is a much more sophisticated
training device
so when i go to displays
he's not an opponent he's a resistance
he's energy
and i displace that
obviously you can see the energy
projecting into him
if he
will do it we'll switch it
okay i'm the training energy
i'm getting him i can feel he put he's
in the ground now i'm just pushing on
the planet right now and he goes to do
it
and i go like this
do you see i absorb the energy of my
shoulder and my elbow do you get it
so
the duration at which he projects my
mass
is about
maybe that long
i'll show you what i mean so that's the
question is how long is he doing the
drill
is related to how much skill he's
developing it would be the difference
between you train one hour once a week
or you train six hours a day you're
going to get more repetitions in the
drill you're going to be much more
skilled so if his
actual drill
is
try to go slow
so he's got my mask now he's going to
put my mass his mass and his movement
energy
into that stain that's about it
then i start to go like this he's not in
the drill anymore
you see i didn't i'm not training him
so again it would be like you lift you
bought a barbell
and you're going to do bench press
and you got the weird one
where you put all the weight on there
and then the part that you push up just
goes up and the weights stay on the
like you're not gonna get strong that
way
you're not gonna that you got ripped off
that's a bad barbell okay
same way
if you have a uke who is a training
device
and your uk goes like this that's a bad
barbell that's not a good uk you wanna
you want to feel and let yourself be
projected he goes locked
okay
so don't absorb the energy in the arm
we're not fighting i'm not counting him
i am a very dynamic very sophisticated
energetic
resistance tool okay
i push in
he goes
okay let's try